dee
ています
ます
はじめましてい
人形です
自己紹介する日中というのもどうなんでしょうかね
今回は
こちらの方で
テックス新種いいバーシティの皆さんからお子様ばをかけいただいて長野から世界へと
いうことで
長野は昔から信州という場所は武道
淫術
の発祥の地とも言われています
そして私は人間になったことによって
非常に大きなピンチから
チャンスに海変えていくことができました
今日はその話を皆さんにを少しお話したいと思います
私は人間になった理由です
今いたのが私の息子なんですが
縁あって買えなくてか私は息子と
13年前から二人で二人三脚を始めることになりました
ある日息子がん
レストランで食事を祖父母としていると
保育園のお友達からどうして君のうちにお母さんがいないの
せっかくレストランに行ったのに食事も喉を通らず帰ってきました
ん
そのうつむいているもそこに対して親ニット
親として何ができるかなと
考えたところ
たまたま
トウ博士という場所に忍者の方がいました
そして私はその
東白紙へ通うことを決断し忍者になることを決めました
人間になる前は私は
小さい頃からブドウ学び
選手として格闘技を行え世界中飛び回っていました
そんな私でしたが
戸隠に入って非常に強い先生方に出会うことができて
鍛えることができました
今日は私が30年かけて学んだことをみんな10分で
お伝えしたいと思います
では忍者ってなんでしょうか
忍者の一番の基本ですねそれは
人間にはルールがありません
皆さんルールがないって言っても
なかなか想像ができないですけれども
本当にルールがないんです
どんなことをしてもいい部分があります
ただそのルールがないという考え方を私は頭が切れたときに初めて
自由な発想
作り始めることができたんです
ここに
一本の棒があります
これは中でも有名な党隠しですねお蕎麦のそば打ちの棒です
ですがこれは忍者にとってみれば
非常に有効な武器になります
そのように柔軟な発想することによって
私たちは
いろいろな場面で対応し
乗り越えることができてきました
今いろんなことの中でルールがあり
柔軟な発想がなければ乗り越えていけませんよね
仕事
なんかの場でも
ストレスが
ありますよね今はとても大きなストレス社会とも言われています
そのストレス社会の中で私も苦しんでいましたん
その苦しんでいる中で忍者に出会い乗り越えることができたと思っています
忍者は常に
現実を見つめています
今この時に乗り越えなければいけないことを
先にも伸ばすことができないですし昨日のことを悔やんでいる場合でもないんです
そして日々の変化に対応しています
われわれはなぜ修行しているのかというとん
将来に対して変化のない世界をつくるのではなくて変化に対応できる人間を育てるため
に修行しています
教え我々はそれに対して厳しい傾向しています
簡単に忍者の教えを3つにまとめます
freemind 自由な考え方ですね枠を取り払っていただきたいんです皆さんから
そして変化に対応してください
そして今を生き機能を悔やむこともなく明日を
案ずることなく暮らしていっていただきたいと思います
そしてこの3つの教えば
前に進みながらも取ることができます
今を生きてへんがに倒して自由になる
そしてまた自由 in な考えを持ち変化に対応して今を生きることができます
今の3つの教えいかがでしたでしょうかね
そして忍者っていうのは
皆さんこうテレビで見たりとかしているとなぜかこう戦うというイメージがありました
ね
でも実際には忍者というのを戦わないことです
人ジスとは戦わずして勝つことです
戦えば
傷つけ合います
彼の死にあります
傷はどんどん広がってしまいます
ですから戦わずに
私たちは逃げることも選択として持っています
このような素晴らしい文化が長野に残っていて
世界の方々がマナーで頂けたら嬉しく思っています
ありがとうございます
少しん
せっかくですから忍者の保存を見せて
帰りたいなと思います
皆さん旅行に行った時に
カバンを持ちになりますよね
がバーン
見えました
ね
とられる嫌だなって思うと皆さん引きますよね
技的に方
私たちは地球の重力に逆らわず
技を落として
という簡単な非常に簡単な
技
皆さんでも明日から今日から使えるぞ
と思ってお見せしました次
ん
いっ
うっ
ん